i got a chance to read a fascinating
paper you um authored called
optoelectronic intelligence
so maybe we can start by uh talking
about this paper and start with the
basic questions what is optoelectronic
intelligence
yeah so in that paper the the concept i
was trying to describe is
sort of an architecture for building
brain-inspired computing
that leverages light for communication
in conjunction with
electronic circuits for computation
in that particular paper a lot of the
work we're doing right now in our
project at nist is focused on
superconducting electronics for
computation i'll go into
why that is but uh
that might make a little more sense in
context if we first
describe what that is in contrast to
which is semiconducting electronics
so is it worth taking a couple minutes
to describe
semiconducting electronics
it might even be worthwhile to step back
and uh talk about electricity and
circuits and how circuits work right
before we talk about super conductivity
right okay
how does the computer work jeff well i i
won't go into everything that makes a
computer work but
let's talk about the
basic building blocks a transistor so
and even more basic than that a
semiconductor material silicon say so
uh in silicon silicon is a semiconductor
and what that means is at low
temperature there are no free charges no
free electrons that can move around so
when you talk about electricity you're
talking about
predominantly electrons moving to
establish electrical currents and they
move under the influence of voltages so
you apply voltages
electrons move around those can be
measured as currents and you can
represent information in that way so
semiconductors are special
in the sense that
they are really malleable so if you have
a semiconductor material it you can
change the number of free electrons that
can move around by putting different
elements different atoms in lattice
sites so
what is a lattice site well a
semiconductor is a crystal which means
all the atoms
that comprise the material
are
at exact locations that are perfectly
periodic in space so if you start at any
one atom and you go along the what are
called the lattice vectors you get to
another atom and another atom and
another atom and for high quality
devices it's important that it's a a
perfect crystal with very few
defects but you can
intentionally replace a silicon atom
with say a phosphorous atom and then you
can you can change the number of free
electrons that are in a region of space
that has that excess of what are called
dopants so picture a device that has a
left terminal and a right terminal
and if you apply a voltage between those
two you can cause electrical current to
flow between them
now we
add a third terminal up on top there and
depending on the voltage between the
left and right terminal and that third
voltage you can you can change that
current so what's commonly done in
digital electronic circuits is to
leave a fixed voltage from left to right
and then
change that voltage that's applied at
what's called the gate the gate of the
transistor so
um what you do is you you make it to
where there's an excess of electrons on
the left excess of electrons on the
right and very few electrons in the
middle and you do this by changing the
concentration of different dopants in
the lattice spatially
and then when you apply a voltage to
that gate you can either cause current
to flow or turn it off and so that's
sort of your zero and one you if you
apply voltage current can flow that
current is representing a digital one
and uh from that from that basic element
you can build up all the complexity of
digital electronic circuits that
have
really had a profound influence on our
society now you're talking about
electrons can you give a sense of what
scale we're talking about when we're
talking about in silicon
being able to mass manufacture these
kinds of gates
yeah so scale in a number of different
senses well at the scale of the silicon
lattice the distance between two atoms
there is half a nanometer so
um
people often like to compare these
things to the the width of a human hair
i think it's some
six orders of magnitude smaller than the
width of a human hair
uh something on that order
so remarkably small we're talking about
individual atoms here and electrons are
of that length scale when they're in
that environment
but there's another sense that scale
matters in digital electronics this is
perhaps the more important sense
although they're related
scale refers to
a number of things it refers to
the size of that transistor so for
example i said you have a left contact a
right contact and some space between
them where the
the gate electrode sits that that's
called the the channel width uh or the
channel length and um
what has enabled what we think of as
moore's law or the continued
increased performance in silicon
microelectronic circuits is the ability
to make that size that feature size ever
smaller ever smaller at a
really remarkable pace i mean
that that feature size has
decreased uh consistently every couple
of years for
the since the 1960s and that was
that was what moore predicted in the
1960s he thought it would continue for
at least two more decades and it's been
much longer than that and so
um
that is why we've been able to fit ever
more devices ever more transistors ever
more computational power on essentially
the same size of chip
so a user sits back and does essentially
nothing you're running the same computer
program but those devices are getting
smaller so they get faster they get more
energy efficient and all of our
computing performance just continues to
improve and we don't have to
think too hard about
what we're what we're doing as say a
software designer something like that i
absolutely don't mean to say that
there's no innovation in
software that are the user side of
things of course there is but
from from the hardware perspective we
just have been given this gift of
continued performance improvement
through this scaling that is ever
smaller feature sizes with very similar
say power consumption that power
consumption is
has not continued to scale in the most
recent decades but
nevertheless we had a really good run
there for a while and now we're down to
gates that are seven nanometers which is
state of the art right now maybe
global foundries is trying to push it
even lower than that i can't keep up
with
where the predictions are that it's
going to end but seven nanometer
uh
seven nanometer transistor
has just just a few tens of atoms along
the length of the conduction pathway so
a naive
semiconductor device physicist would
think you can't go much further than
that without
some kind of revolution in the way we
think about the physics of our devices
is there something to be said about
the mass manufacture of these devices
right right so that's another thing so
how have we been able to
make those transistors smaller and
smaller well
companies like intel global foundries
they invest a lot of money in the
lithography so how are these uh chips
actually made well one of the most
important steps is this
what's called ion implantation so you
have you start with sort of a pristine
silicon crystal
and then using photolithography which is
a technique where you can pattern
different shapes using light
you can define which regions of space
you're going to implant with different
uh
different species of ions that are going
to change the local electrical
properties right there
so by using ever shorter wavelengths of
light and different kinds of optical
techniques and different kinds of
lithographic techniques things that go
far beyond
my knowledge base
you can just simply shrink that feature
size down and you say you're at seven
nanometers well the wavelength of light
that's being used is over 100 nanometers
that's already deep in the uv so
how how are those minut features
patterned well there's there's an
extraordinary amount of innovation that
has gone into that but nevertheless it
stayed very consistent in this ever
shrinking feature size and now the
question is can you make it smaller and
even if you do do you still continue to
get performance improvements but that's
another kind of scaling where
these these companies have been able to
so okay you you picture a chip that has
a processor on it well that chip is not
made as a chip it's made as a on a wafer
and um
using photolithography you basically
print the same pattern
on different dies all across the wafer
multiple layers tens probably
probably a hundred some layers in a
mature foundry process and and you do
this on ever bigger wafers too that's
another aspect of scaling that's
occurred in the last several decades so
now you have this 300 millimeter wafer
it's like as big as a pizza and it has
maybe a thousand processors on it and
then you dice that up using a saw and
now you can sell these things
so cheap because the the manufacturing
process was so streamlined i think a
technology as revolutionary as silicon
microelectronics
has to have that kind of
uh manufacturing scalability which i
will just emphasize i believe is
enabled by
physics it's not i mean that of course
there's human ingenuity that goes into
it but at least from my
my side where where i sit it sure looks
like the physics of our universe allows
us to to produce that and we've we've
discovered how
more so than we've invented it although
of course we have invented it humans
have invented it but it was it's almost
as if it was there waiting for us to to
discover it you mean the entirety of it
or are you specifically talking about
the techniques of photo lithography like
the optics involved i mean the entirety
of the scaling down to the seven
nanometers that you're able to have
electrons
not interfere with each other in such a
way that
you could still have gates like that's
enabled to achieve that scale spatial
and temporal
seems to be very special and is enabled
by the physics of our world all of the
things you just said so starting with
the the silicon material itself
silicon is a unique semiconductor it has
essentially ideal properties for making
a specific kind of transistor that's
extraordinarily useful so
i mentioned that
silicon has uh well when you make a
transistor you have this gate contact
that sits on top of the conduction
channel and depending on the voltage you
apply there you pull more carriers into
the conduction channel or push them away
so it becomes more or less conductive
in order to have that work without just
sucking those carriers right into that
contact you need a very thin insulator
and and part of scaling has been to
gradually decrease the thickness of that
of that gate insulator so they can
use a roughly similar voltage and still
have the same current voltage
characteristics so the material that's
used to do that or i should say was
initially used to do that was a silicon
dioxide which just naturally grows on
the silicon surface so you expose
silicon to the atmosphere that we
breathe and
uh well if you're manufacturing you're
going to
purify these gases but nevertheless that
that what's called a native oxide will
grow there there are essentially no
other materials on the entire periodic
table that have as good of a
gate insulator as as that silicon
dioxide and that that has to do with
nothing but the physics of the
interaction between silicon and oxygen
and if it wasn't that way transistors
could not
they they could not perform in
nearly the the degree of capability that
they have and that that has to do with
the way that the the oxide grows the
reduced density of defects there it's
it's insulation meaning essentially it's
energy gaps you can apply a very large
voltage there without having current
leak through it so that's physics right
there
um
there are other things too silicon is a
semiconductor in in an elemental sense
you you only need silicon atoms a lot of
other semiconductors you need two
different kinds of atoms like a compound
from group three and a compound from
group five that opens you up to lots of
defects that can occur where one atom's
not sitting quite at the lattice site it
is and it's switched with another one
that degrades performance
but then also on the side that you
mentioned with the the manufacturing
we have access to light sources that can
produce these very short wavelengths of
light
how does photolithography occur well you
actually put this polymer on top of your
wafer
and you expose it to light and then you
use a
aqueous chemical processing to dissolve
away the regions that were exposed to
light and leave the regions that we're
not
and
we are blessed with these polymers that
have the right property where
they can
cause scission events where the polymer
splits where a photon hits i mean you
know maybe maybe that's not too
surprising but i don't know it all it
all comes together to have this really
complex uh manufacturable ecosystem
where
very sophisticated technologies can be
devised
and it works quite well
and amazing like you said with a
wavelength at like 100 nanometers or
something like that you're still able to
achieve on this polymer precision of
whatever whatever we said seven
nanometers yeah i think i've heard like
four nanometers being talked about
something like that yes
you